- On this episode we
talk Snapchat marketing,
email marketing, and what
I'm up to in making an app.
(electronic music)
♫ You ask questions.
♫ I answer them.
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 122
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm very laser focused
this Monday morning.
It's that six a.m. yoga
Stunwin that gets me
into the right mindset, feeling very good.
I had a tremendous weekend.
Did some longform Facebook posts on Sunday
that completely ripped the house down.
Getting a lot of head
nods here from the team.
Felt really good about that.
So that's intriguing.
I'm really enjoying the interaction.
Spent a ton of time with the
kids, feeling pretty good.
I can smell football in
the air as training camps
are starting to open up very shortly.
That excites me but
I'm really ready India
for a very, very, very, very laser...
as a matter-of-fact,
Game Boy is cool but if
laser tag was on the table
that would make much more sense
for this lasery Monday
focus that I'm bringing
to episode 122 of
the #AskGaryVee show.
So, India, I don't know
how your weekend was but
- Great.
- Really?
- I'm a Jets fan.
- That's nice,
I very much know this you saw my response
to you wearing that shirt.
I'm pumped India is a
Jets fan is a good pro...
by the way,
yeah, we this show has not seen,
when did we, wait a minute,
we went through Jets season last year.
- [India] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Oh yeah.
- But it was such a shit season that
it didn't really impact the show.
I have bigger hopes this year.
So get ready I think uh, the
show is a hell of a lot more
momentum going into this year.
So, India let's get into
the shooooooow.
(laughs)
- [India] That's too funny.
- Where are our t-shirts on this?
People are demanding
the shooooow t-shirts.
I don't see any of the designers around.
I saw Zak coming up the elevator--
- [Voiceover] Making their
working on the shirt.
- Maybe they are working on the shirt.
Let's go.
- [Voiceover] Natalie asks,
"If you were a college graduate
"today and didn't have your family business
"how would you handle the job market?"
- Natalie thank you so much.
Big shout out to
everybody who's out in LA.
That was a really phenomenal
night for me as well.
A lot of peeps came out, I appreciate it.
Well, first of all, I wouldn't
attack the job market,
because even at the age of nine or ten,
long before I even realized
my parents had a liquor store
as my dad managed that store
and was buying into a business
I was already slinging, as
you heard in episode 118,
you know blue curtains and alarm clocks.
And clearly you've heard
the stories of lemonade
and baseball cards.
There is no attacking the
job market from my DNA
because I would try to start a business
especially right now.
I would completely take
advantage of the fact
that there is an enormous
amount of dumb money
trying to become
investors in start-ups.
Meaning, unlike the
generation where I became
an angel investor in
2009, 2008, 2010, 2011.
Right now every dentist,
every real estate agent,
every trust fund baby in
their thirties, forties,
fifties, sixties, seventies, and eighties
anybody who had a good
career on Wall Street
is now an investor looking
for their Mark Zuckerberg.
I would take advantage of that.
I would network.
I assume if I was in college
I would ask professors.
I would ask friends and family.
I would just ask.
I think when you're at the bottom,
asking is quite important.
And so I would ask for at bats,
try to network.
I would use the incredible
tool that is known as Twitter
and I would be replying
to people that I aspire
to get in touch with.
I don't, you know it's funny
to me to see the people
that give up after asking to meet with me
for a few minutes,
after three or four nos.
And I know that I'm inducing
now a ton of Twitter chatter
to meet with me.
And I hope you saw the
video I made for myself,
the advice I've given myself.
DRock, give them a two second clip.
I need to get my shit together
so I apologize I'm letting you down.
But the truth is I need
to heed to this advice
I'm giving myself.
You know, so I won't see you
but I would have saw you six months ago
and Cuban, or Jack Welsh,
or Zucks, or Elon Musk,
you just never know when they'll
actually sit down with you.
And then there's a
million people that maybe
you don't know who've been successful,
who've got leverage, who've got money.
And so I would attack the
reality of the marketplace.
And the reality of the
marketplace right this second
is tons of cash, looking
for young people with ideas.
I think it's a broken bubble.
I think that gets exposed.
I think 99% of people
are not going to deliver
on that investment.
I think I'd be one of the 1% that would
deliver on that investment.
So I'd be looking for while in college
and like I did in college
instead of looking to
hook-up and do keg stands
I'd be looking for business partners
and business opportunities.
I think for anybody else
that is not wired like me
which I think is a far majority
of this show's audience
I would tell you this piece of advice.
If you were 22 years old,
if you were the amount of people
that settle for the first paying job
versus living with 19 friends on the floor
and eating 99 cent meals blows my mind
in lieu of trying to get your dream job
versus what you've settled for.
Please from 22 to 24 don't settle.
Go for your dream job.
Pound for it.
And if you can't get
into VaynerMedia (ping)
then go for the second
best, or third best,
or fourth best on your list.
Please start with the
moon and go backwards.
The amount of you that start at a hilltop
and just settle there
is an enormous mistake
because 22 to 24 is when you should live
really, really humble, ghetto, dirt.
Like that's it,
that's the time.
To settle in in the
middle only lends itself
to so much upside.
So aspire for as high as you possibly can
and be patient.
it sucks not having a job in September
when all your friends do.
Or your friends that were
juniors the year before
are going back to school
and the pressure is on
and maybe your parents don't
like that you don't have a job
but that's exactly when you
should be buying random stuff
at Goodwill and selling it
on eBay to pay your $80.00
worth of rent because you
have 94 roommates in a studio.
That's it, get dirty.
Cause, and I know a paused there,
cause getting dirty is the price
to having what you want.
The dramatic misunderstanding that amazing
things come with a price.
A lot of people talk about rich kids.
I really negatively look at rich kids
because I look negatively at my kids
because they're about to be rich kids.
That's just real.
Sorry Xander and Misha, eat it.
But you know what comes with the price
of being a rich kid?
People completely do,
you've basically lost
in the game of winners.
You've basically from day
one you were born into money.
You actually aren't
good, you were handed it.
You suck.
That's it, you've lost.
That's the price that comes along with it.
And take it from somebody
who cried everyday
because his dad had a
small family business
and I was petrified because
I knew I had the talent
that everybody would say
things were handed to me.
Cried everyday with my mom on the phone
I'm not coming into the family business
even though I could help it,
even though I want to, I don't.
Because then everybody is going to say,
that it was handed to me.
In the scheme of things I was an idiot
I didn't realize how
small it was to the world.
But everything's got a price.
Everything's got a price.
You're beautiful?!
LIfe is much better when you're beautiful.
That's what we all say.
I agree with that.
But, more realistically, you
get completely disrespected.
You get disrespected.
You can't be smart, you can't be good,
you're just too beautiful.
I'm serious.
I'm really tired of people
thinking everybody's
got it better.
Everybody has advantages.
You know what the
advantages of being ghetto
and on welfare and being
nothing and having nothing
being a child of a homeless parent.
You know what the advantage is?
You're (bleep) angry.
You've got a ridiculous
chip on your shoulder.
You want to stick it to everybody.
All of 'em.
Use what you've got.
That was good.
- [Staphon] I wasn't sure
if that was another pause.
- You weren't sure.
We're ready?
No, that's it.
We can move on.
- [Steve] There's an
article making the rounds
saying that the old lady ideals
who are vaguely financially successful
are the only reason any one of those
are making any money is
because their parents
were able to pay off their
college loans, basically.
- Yeah
- [Steve] Basically.
- Yeah, I mean because the college loans
are bringing everyone down.
I mean this college loan...
I mean college is the racket.
It is the singular racket.
These are businesses that are...
I was just walking with James Orsini
and he said I went to
college this weekend.
I don't want to blow
up his daughter's spot
but like wow.
You know what his line was?
It was like Disneyland.
Of course it was like Disneyland, James.
They made it look like Disneyland
so you buy it.
Like the racket, the racket.
College loans that you can't
even declare bankruptcy
to get out of.
That gives you a piece of
paper that does not map
to anything that's going
on in the real world.
Zero.
Zero reality.
Other than the jobs, lawyers, doctors...
I know the cliche shit
but I'm talking business
and you're not watching
this for lawyer shit.
So business just does not map.
Like if I could spur some
excitement right now,
is if you were watching this
and you were collecting
debt to go to college
to be a business person, quit right now.
Send this email to mom.
Sorry mom, (bleep) off.
I don't want you to wrap your self-esteem
into little Johnny's
life so you can tell your
(bleep) friends that he goes to Dartmouth.
He's going to (bleep) lose,
get him the (bleep) out.
Off to a solid start here, huh?
(laughter)
India?
- It's from Saba and Anika.
- Oh, video.
- Hey, Gary! Huge fans of your show.
We've watched all 109 episodes.
- And we thought it's about
time we ask you a question.
- Here it is.
I co-founded Ice Cream
Social a few months ago
and we're planning to have a
livestream summit in September.
Here's my question.
Without having a huge
following and brand equity
- how do we approach
companies to participate
in our livestream summit?
- Thanks, Gary.
(electronic music)
- Hold on, I like the music.
That's a tremendous question
and actually a very easy
one for me to answer.
You need to sell people the
upside versus the reality.
Selling often times is also
predicated on where you're going
versus what you have to offer now--
(electronic music)
India.
And so what I would sell
to them is like look
we're two badass chicks,
we're going to win
and you're going to want
to be a part of this.
And if you invest in us now,
if you give me a $1,000 check
now although we might only be worth $350,
or it might only be
worth $500 in your mind,
I promise you that when you
write us a check for $2,000
in two years, it's going to be $10,000
cause I'm going to give
you an 80% discount
cause you Ricky Thompson
are making the committment
and you're believing in me.
That is absolutely the only way to sell
something that you don't
have is to sell something
that you're about to become
Period.
And by the way as somebody
who bets on that kind of stuff
all day long there are plenty
of people that like the idea
of locking in the next
three years of sponsorship.
And, again, if you guys bail on this
you know you gotta give the money back.
You gotta be honorable.
It's a long game.
The only way for you to
get sponsors is to sell
where you're going and make promises
of financial upside
for them in the future.
Again, hey conemaker, hey people...
this is ice cream social, right?
Like I'm not exactly sure
exactly what you're doing
but hey business that
cares about the audience,
this year it's going to be smaller
but we're hustling and this is who we are.
And they're either going
to believe you or not.
This is something that
I'm talking a lot about
with people who have worked
here for two or three years
at Vayner and are complaining about stuff.
And I'm look if you've worked
for me for two to three years
and you don't fully, blindly believe in me
then you should not work here.
If I've not been able to
prove to you at this point
we're not getting anywhere
because my patience
is running out and so...
I don't know why I just
wanted to randomly say that
for anybody who's
watching at VaynerMedia.
The point of it is, the point of it is
you, they're either gonna...oh, I remember
they're either going to trust you or not
when you sell them the
dream of where you're going
over the next two to three years.
So sell them the dream
and then execute the dream.
- [Voiceover] Melissa asks,
"When are you going to make
"an app and what would it be like?
"why not have a jab jab jab app?"
- Melissa, on this show I
talk a whole lot about betting
on your strengths and not
focusing on your weaknesses.
I as a product, leaders don't
feel like very strong on it.
I've got to much going on right now.
I don't want to stretch myself thin.
Everytime I build products
they're always half pregnant.
If I ever build an app
or product it will be
the singular thing I do
or at least the one-a a la VaynerMedia.
And so I'm not interested in building it.
It doesn't, like even the question...
It's crazy, India.
Like even when I started
like answering the question
it doesn't feel good.
Like I was clearly passionate
about the things I talked
about in the first question.
I'm clearly not passionate right now.
You can even tell by my general
energy in answering this.
I just have zero interest
in building an app.
I'm aware that apps are good.
That's the word on the street.
They do well.
You can build big businesses.
I understand but I understand
myself better than my ambition
to scratch that itch which
is actually quite low.
It's been higher in the past
but I think I mature
along the way as well.
And, you know, sorta
eating my own dog food
and I just don't, I
haven't invested in it.
The only reason this show exists
is I invested in infrastructure.
If I decide to hire two
full-time developers
and really, really decide to
hire two full-time developers
which I could do at any point.
That's not the problem.
It's me giving them, him and her,
the energy to actually architect the map.
Right now I just don't feel
compelled to do that at all.
And so, and so I'm actually gonna like...
you can see I've brought the big comma in.
This is where I want to
make it more valuable
for a lot of you.
Way to many of you and
obviously this weekend
I got to see a lot of
engagement and really dug into
some rabbit holes on you.
Way to many of you are doing
one of two things incorrectly,
in my opinion.
One you're letting the market
tell you what you should do.
You should start an app,
you should be a guru,
you should sell ebooks,
you should start a company.
You should, you should, you
should, you should, right?
Number two.
You are actually convincing
yourself because you aspire
to be something you're not.
I aspire to build the next
Instagram or Snapchat.
That'd be really rad,
it'd be really great.
It's just not in me.
So more self awareness,
less pondering,
less listening, listen to yourself.
Except when yourself is bullshitting you
then counter it with stop
bullshitting me, Gary.
Alright, sorry.
- [India] (mumbles)
- Hi Gary, my name is Annmarie
and I'm wondering how small businesses
can best utilize Snapchat?
Like should they be posting
coupons or promotions
or maybe doing day in the life diaries?
Would love to know your answer, thanks.
- Annemarie?
Annemarie, the answer is yes.
All of the above.
You need to put out compelling content.
Compelling content in my opinion
falls into two very distinct categories.
One, entertainment and escapism.
Two, utility and value.
That's it.
That's how I see it.
Either you're entertaining
me because I need to escape
the reality of I can't pay
rent, that I have 94 roommates
because this idiot on the
Internet told me to find
my dream job.
(rewind sound)
buying random stuff at
Goodwill and selling it on eBay
to pay your $80.00 worth of rent because
you have 94 roommates in a studio.
That's it.
Get dirty.
Or--
(laughter)
You like the recall?
You like the recall, Steve.
You always like the recalls.
- Well, you know, callbacks are good.
- Callbacks.
Thank you for the proper terminology.
Or two you are a utility.
Like you just bring absolute value.
I think the show works
because I think I mixed
both in pretty nicely.
But it's one or the other.
So on Snapchat you either gotta do that
entertain them, make it funny.
Don't forget the context of Snapchat,
skew is younger.
You know a lot of it
is mundane silly stuff.
Or you can bring utility
which is you gamify it
and say here's a coupon
or a code, save it because
it's going to disappear.
You play with that.
Utility or entertainment.
It's very clear.
It's funny.
You led the question.
Amber, you know the answer.
I love having you on the show
but you absolutely led the answer
which is you gave the
examples that would work.
You know what to do.
Now it's less about asking
me and more about doing it.
- [India] (mumbles) Amy Porterfield.
- Amy Porterfield.
I know Amy.
- Hi, I'm Amy Porterfield and
I've got a question for you.
So in your book, The Thank You
Economy you talk a lot about
letting your audience
decide if they want to get
to know you more versus
persuading them that they should.
So when it comes to email
marketing what are some tips
you have for communicating
with your audience
in a way that doesn't kill the connection
because you're being to persuasive?
- Hmmm.
That's a good question.
Email marketing is a tricky one.
You know I think, Amy,
it's funny you reference
Thank You Economy.
I think the answer to
email marketing is found
in my next book title which
is Jab, Jab, Jab Right Hook.
I mean think about all the email services
you are signed up to
and/or have been over the
last three or four years
as so many of you start to siphon off
of being on email lists.
So many of those email
lists are in pure utility.
Right? They're retail,
they're giving you deals.
They're very action-oriented.
Nobody in that space is
throwing enough jabs.
We at Wine Library aren't.
I still think I want to,
I'm going to use this
to take my own advice.
We need to start sending at
least once or twice a month.
It's so hard because you're
siphoned on the drug of sales.
But you've got to put out content.
As a matter of fact,
Steve, I want you to work
with Brandon right now.
I want to send an email with
the last five stories we wrote
on the site and I want
to send it out as just
with a title of like Reading
For You Around the Wine World.
Although let's play with it a little bit.
So that.
So instead of everyone being
like here's a deal, $49.99.
Game Boy, old school.
You know you need to start putting out
the history of Nintendo.
Right?
So more content.
More content that kind of allows people
to be less on the defense.
Every mail that comes in
is like it's at you, right?
With content that has
no purpose other than
to entertain or inform or
bring utilitarian value
to the user, you're
getting their guard down.
You're bringing them
value which opens them up
so much more for the sale.
And so I think that's the way to go.
I really do.
I think and I think mixing
the two is intriguing.
You know I'm curious what
Steve and I are about to do
with Wine Library lends itself
to more content in the mix
of the sale.
And I don't like blending
jabs and right hooks
but I always like testings.
A bunch of people always ask me, like
Gary did you read Jab, Jab, Jab Right Hook
these posts on Facebook
and Instagram this weekend
don't feel native.
Well maybe they are.
I mean by results of the way
people responded to Facebook.
Maybe they're very native,
maybe native changes
because native does change.
And so, always testing.
Always testing.
That's it?
- [India] Yep.
- Great.
That was a good show.
I like that show.
Question of the day and actually lurkers
a lot of you came out this weekend.
I need more of you.
To define a lurker to you if
you do not know what I mean
it's you're a piece of crap.
You watch a show.
You take, take, take.
I'm not charging you for it
and you've never commented
which is the only fuel and
payback that I ask for.
The only one.
You just take it.
You're just a taker.
You know what?
You're not a lurker, you're a taker.
That feels even worse.
You're a goddamn taker.
So please if you're a taker,
jump in and leave a comment
and say hey I'm enjoying the show.
Hey cool. well let me answer
the following question
which I think is interesting.
What is your favorite email
list that you're on right now?
Not all time, right this second.
Which email service is
providing you the most value?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Good tight show.
(electronic music)